where are you keeping the ring because  you don't get to wear it it's a good  question  I know it's not on this finger I don't  know where it is they probably don't  want to tell me because I will go  looking for it like I miss it what is  your favorite quality about your fiance  his strength  what about cringe-worthy moments  watching the show back  the only cringe-worthy moment I had was  the hot tub scene and having my family  with Peter  yeah when his hands are slowly gliding  up your back like sorry mom sorry dad  that was cringeworthy have you and your  fiance been watching the show I would  prefer that he didn't watch everything  but he needs to know like everything  that's going on so he can process  everything like that's just the kind of  person that he is so he watches at all  what was the ultimate deciding factor  for you when it comes down to those two  guys it's really just a feeling it's  that x-factor  [Music]